all right
christian mccaffrey has his contract we
know that
will joe mixon be one of the next ones
to get his and what will he do if he
does not
there is some speculation that the
bengals are bracing for a holdout from
joe mixon if he doesn't get paid i'm
told that he hasn't even gotten to the
point where he's thought about that
chris and and he's not one of the guys
that scream out entering year four
he must draw a line in the sand i don't
think he's done enough yet to justify
drawing a line in the sand and holding
out dalvin cook yes alvin kamara yes i
feel like joe mixon's not yet in that
category uh am i right or am i wrong
well i i think talent wise mike i mean
let's talk about this i think he's in
that category talent-wise i don't know
if he has the
numbers
and the offense has had the success
maybe to back it up or
merit what he would be asking for to get
the public pressure on the bangles and
all those things let alone hey we know
the bengals they took a risk on a guy
who had a pretty significant off the
field issue at oklahoma so i think that
all has to be taken into account but
like mike i mean literally i mean he is
he's phenomenal talent if somebody told
me hey listen i think joe mixon is one
of the five best running backs in
football i wouldn't sit here and go oh
you're crazy that's stupid
no i think i mean when you talk about
derek henry christian mccaffrey barkley
dalvin cook nick chubb
zeke elliott leonard fournette
i mean joe mixon to me deserves to be in
that conversation he does there's no
doubt about it so he is a special
football player you know i just don't
know if kind of the numbers and the wins
and all of that are going to be enough
to
advance the public pressure on the
bengals to let him command big top
dollar right now
and here's the other thing too we're
talking about the bengals and we know
that the bengals do things differently
than anyone else and if joe mixon holds
out they'll just shrug and they'll find
somebody else to play the position right
remember when carson palmer decided he
was done with the bengals they just
squatted on him and uh they would have
continued to squat on him if the trade
hadn't fallen out of the sky that
allowed them to move carson palmer to
the raiders for way too much in return
so um yeah i i think that it would be a
mistake for mixon to hold out because
the bengals aren't going to react the
way that he would think and the point is
even though there's reporting out there
suggesting it's something that could
happen mixon hasn't even crossed that
bridge yet there's a lot that's going to
occur before we even get to the point
where someone can hold out from training
camp there may be no training camp to
hold out from so yeah that's right let's
see where it goes
aren't even relevant
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports